Voiceover:Below is a drawing
of vectors U,V, and W.
Sort the cards according
to the quantity they represent.
If a card doesn't represent
any of the quantities,
it should be left unsorted.
Let's see what they have over here.
This, they've drawn vector V here in blue,
vector W here in magenta,
and then vector U here in purple.
Let's see what they choices are.
The rectangular coordinates 3,4.
If we go 3 along the X axis
in the positive direction,
and then we go up 4, 1,2,3,4,
we get to the head of vector V.
It's tail, it started at the origin.
This could, right over
here, represent vector V.
If we say hey look, the tail of our vector
is going to be the origin,
then this coordinate, right over here,
represents the head of a vector.
This could be a
representation for vector V.
Another way to think about it is vector V,
from it's tail, goes 3 in
the horizontal direction
and 4 in the vertical direction.
That's another way to think about it.
I would say that's definitely
a representation of vector V.
The number 5.
The number 5 won't represent a vector.
This is just a number.
This could be a magnitude,
but to be a vector,
we need a magnitude and a direction.
Right over here we have
the magnitude of vector V.
Let's think about whether 5
could be the magnitude of vector V.
If 5 is the magnitude,
it would be the length of this vector.
We could think about that
from the Pythagorean theorem.
This side, right over here, has length 3.
That side over there has length 4.
You might recognize this
as a 3,4,5 triangle.
Another way to think about it
if we use the Pythagorean theorem
3 squared is 9 plus 4
squared plus 16 is 25,
which is going to be
this magnitude squared.
The magnitude of vector V is 5.
We could throw that right over here.
The length of this, how
we depicted the vector.
Let's look at vector U.
Vector U is just a shifted
representation of vector V.
Notice, we started its tail,
3 to the right and 4 up.
Vector U is really the
same thing as vector V.
We don't care about where they start.
We just care about, from
the tail to the head,
how much do you move in
the horizontal direction,
and how much do you move
in the vertical direction,
and for both of them, you move positive 3
in the horizontal and
positive 4 in the vertical.
Vector U really is the
same thing as vector V
if we're thinking in vector terms.
Vector W, if we start at the tail
to go to the head, we have to
go negative 3 in the X direction
and negative 4 in the Y direction.
Vector W is the negative of vector V,
or the negative of vector U,
but it's not equal to either one of them.
We're all done, we have set up.
These are the quantities that
are in the appropriate buckets.